hallo und herzlich willkommen zum 28 was
man gemeinsam miteinander bestreiten wir
haben heute kraft ausdauer rücken als
haupt thema mit mobilisation und
kräftigen die viki ist mit dabei ist
peter bin für euch da wieder und wir
haben heute wieder einen spezialgast
denn andreas graf einen zugführer
leistungssportler von bahnradsport
zweiter bei der letzten
weltmeisterschaft erst bei der
europameisterschaft andreas was fehlt in
deiner meinung
ja hallo in einer reihe fehlt eindeutig
genau die olympier mit einer dann hat
man den kasten von der sammlung ein
komplettpaket und den bin ich hart daran
zu arbeiten wir mit 1600 derzeit was ich
auf und denke man heute das workout
machen zumal jetzt meine medaille
das freut mich natürlich zu hören mit
dieser positiven energie hätte gesagt
statt makellos bewegen wir uns aber
bevor ich habe gehört du läufst runs für
radfahren auch über 3000 kilometer im
jahr laufen das muss der andere ein oder
andere erst einmal beim rauslaufen also
da kann man sich von beiden eine große
scheibe abschneiden beginnt mit
aufwärmen laufen am stand der technik
genau der übung sein oder perfekt zum
reinkommen
also haben wir leider kann man etwas
gerne gerade haben wir leider ganz
aufbauen können
man kann es aufstehen können aber
schritte gehen abwehren anfang aller
fortschritte gehen bevor der muskelkater
dann wagen zu groß wird bleiben bestehen
greis war die arme vorwärts und
rückwärts kreisen 30 kilometer hast du
vor dir bis olympia olympia wir uns noch
so 15 20.000 kilometer also wir uns auch
besser als olympia fünfter 20.000
kilometer
man kann jetzt hochrechnen das sind
viele kilometer im jahr
die da an die ems auto sitzt und
entsprechend natürlich auch immer in
einer aerodynamik opposition drinnen ist
eine vor eine zurück gegen gleich
angreifen
und natürlich muss man diese war ich
sehr
allerdings ist darauf war es nicht ganz
so wird aus statt ok einmal kurz aus
locker aussieht und das nehmen wir mit
und laufen wir wieder kurz am stand das
aktivieren wieder
aber schauen wir mal nicht nur im kreise
seiner box anlauf machen das haben bis
jetzt eine rolex oft die hände dazu
boxen auch die hände ausstrecken zu
bewegung dazu und ausloggen gerne gleich
die kreisstelle diagonal den oberkörper
nach vorn handy links und rechts runter
also rumpf drehen in der vorbeugen oder
zu atmen aufwärmen mobilisieren und
richten uns wieder auf fahrt remagen
oberkörper in der aufrechten position
links nach rechts und umgekehrt
ich danke dir mal den oberkörper trainer
den kopf links und rechts hin und her
und nach oben und nach unten
und gibt man den kopf von der linken auf
die rechte seite
laufen wir wieder runter waffen locker
am stand immer wieder dazu ein bauen
einen knie und einmal anfassen
unterschiedlichste kleine bewegungen
dazu nehmen an die es geht richtung
olympia was ist deine spezialdisziplin
meine spezial des ministers madison ist
man zu zweit
das ist es immer hinter moped nach vorn
es um hinter mopedfahrer auf der band
seiner vorlage zum oben der unterricht
im rennen unten und wahren sie begegnen
übergibt der schnelle den langsamen und
sehr schnelles rennen also müssen die 50
kilometer 15 minuten fertig okay das
geld wirklich wie hast du das mit dem
moped diesem ort ist endlich
steherrennen das fahrzeug gar nicht gibt
oder art journey wenden und ich vor dass
mindestens einen tag
das verwechseln sagt ok stehenbleiben
handgelenk kreisen
also hände zusammen und einfach lockere
kreise richtung wechseln noch einmal die
richtung wechseln
wir mobilisieren einfach wieder alle
gelenke durch das man entsprechend da
gut vorbereitet dann ins training gehen
können elke seitlich hoch geben
unterarme kreisen und die richtung
wechseln
händeschütteln becken kreisen gerne
ergänzt einfach die hände in die hüften
hineingeben und das becken in einer
kreisbewegung die eine kreise große
kreis ich immer ein bisschen variieren
links und rechts seite wechseln richtung
wechseln das ist wie lange bist du schon
im leistungssport leistungssport
unterwegs an mein erstes jahr vollzeit
sportler war 2003
ok also jetzt doch ich mag was ich hab
meiner karriere kann man sich ja
ausloggen was planst dann auch also ich
werde dann auch verständlich wenn die
sportliche leitung orientieren
mir ist das immer schon ging mit jungen
leuten die am sprung zum profi zum
arbeiten und in die lichten würde ich
dann okay was hat ihnen die betreuung
schiene in die betreuung china war die
jungen zu unterstützen wo was sie machen
sollen
ich bin nicht einzuholen so eine
mischung also nur betreuer ist jetzt
nicht so dass wir einen trainer und
betreuer nach so das gesamtpaket sehr
gerne die hände aufs knie kreisen im
kniegelenk richtung wechseln
und kurz aus locker anheben eines linke
bein hoch thomas stein sprunggelenk
kreisen richtung wechseln seite wechseln
zweites bein hoch richtung wechseln und
noch mal kurz aus lockern ich glaube wir
sagen ganz gut vorbereitet die übungen
die man für euch vorbereitet haben acht
stück machen wir jetzt einmal
durchführen rücken das als 30 sekunden
wenn wir den rücken belasten dann auch
manchmal 30 sekunden pause das ganze 819
über gelang und dann werden wir
mobilisieren hineingehen das heißt erst
wirklich den block an übungen und dann
den block an mobilisieren mit welcher
übung rockstar anfang an dicke
ok also stand lage ist eine übung genau
tag x vor ein weinstand hände vorbei
nach oben
genau in die opposition hinein
muskelspannung aufbauen und wieder
hochkommen und das ganze manchmal 30
sekunden lang auf einer seite das heißt
schon mal einen guten standort wo wir
jetzt das arme aus und dann statt menge
los mit 30 sekunden arbeitszeit eine du
bist bereit windrad nicht passt dann
legen wir los preis sekunden stand waage
in der mischung mit good morning das
heißt aufrichten und immer wieder in den
einwand stand hinunter gehen und das
jetzt es ist komplett egal ob in der
oberen positionen ab perfekten waage
drinnen bin oder ob wieder von der
beweglichkeit oder vom gleichgewicht ja
nicht ganz angekommen wichtig ist dass
ihr euch bemüht in die position
hineinzukommen und den oberkörper wieder
aufrichten und da kommt sie muskulär
genau in dem bereich der belastung ein
dem raum in dem gesäß und unterdrücken
beziehungsweise oberschenkelrückseite
die ganze hintere kette ist er mit dabei
30 sekunden sei durch kurz aus lockern
und dann die zweite seite mit gehen
sollst du für ein tipp für unsere mit
trainieren mit turner für euch zu hause
da
das gleichgewicht vielleicht ein bisserl
besser in den griff kriegt wenn man halt
jetzt ganz viel mehr darstellen und die
[Applaus]
probier mal das gerne aus aber dann in
der zeit halte und im wechsel immer
wieder kurz stehenbleiben und
entsprechend das gleichgewicht aber
beruhigen
ok dann legen wir los zweite runde
zweite seite 30 sekunden und geht's los
und du kannst natürlich wenn es das
zuhause variieren möchte einmal die
hände nach vorne zur seite nach können
sich ruhig fordern überhaupt kein
problem wir haben jetzt eine zweite
variante vor ist das nicht ganz so gut
geht dass sie das entsprechend mitmachen
kennst fünf sekunden noch 212 das
auslagern ausschüttung zweite übung
schulterblatt fix autoren ja das ist ja
etwas glaube in der position dass man da
immer wieder wechseln muss oder dass man
das immer wieder fixiert haben aus der
schultergelenke weil man dann halt
andere kraftübertragung hinkriegt oder
andere kraft übertragen aber gerade die
schulterpartie ist stundenlang ja sehr
stark belastet durch die ganzen schlägen
das mir haben ja ganz praktisch direkt
mit die schultern ok und durch das ist
bisher wirklich sehr gut trainiert also
dass die schulterblätter zeit fixiert
und muskulär abgesichert in der position
als sein können wir haben zwei übungen
für euch vorbereitet eine standard
variante und eine komplexere variante
und wir zeigen euch jetzt einmal beide
vor
das heißt an die darf die bieten legt ja
mal auf den rücken ihr kämpft die übung
aber zur wiederholung albums seitlich in
die matte oder in den boden hinein jetzt
dem bauch versuchen so gut wie möglich
spannungsfrei zu halten das heißt wir
machen kann sieht ab sondern er macht
die übung drückt das ellbogengelenk in
den boden bis sieht der oberkörper
hochhebt und der ist mit so wenig
spannung aus der bauchmuskulatur wie
möglich also immer wieder daran erinnern
nicht mit dem bauch hochziehen sondern
der ellbogen drückt in den boden hinein
und das muss jetzt gar nicht so hoch
sein her so wie es mal bei
am ende siegt aber wie gesagt eine
variante und die zweite variante ihr
geht es in bauchlage legten oberkörper
auf der matte ab cancer gerne den kopf
ablegen ist überhaupt kein problem und
erhebt seitlich den eltern nach oben
genau und da kommen die gleichen muskeln
muskulatur hinein nur mit weniger
belastung und dadurch auch für jedermann
gut schaffbar nachdem ihr bayerische
position satz und beim üben satz auch
für euch zuhause 30 sekunden übungszeit
und los geht's das ist wie gesagt eine
übung wo ich ganz stark darauf
konzentrieren müssen das jetzt diese
kleine muskelgruppe die man jetzt da
belasten auch entsprechend aktivieren
kennt ja ansteuern können das heißt das
ist ein ganz schwieriger punkt den
kleinen muskel sagen jetzt zu arbeiten
und die großen muskeln aus homer
dementsprechend sagen nicht arbeiten
bauchmuskeln ruhig locker entspannt und
hinten muss im rücken gearbeitet werden
abbasi kunden noch zeit ist aus 30
sekunden haben wir wieder geschafft
schulterblatt faktoren seien somit
erledigt okay dann haben wir jetzt eine
übung für den oberen rechten
schulterblatt fixateur an drinnen gehabt
dann wechselt er an die bitte in die
bauchlage das heißt oberkörper
aufrichten die übung kemmer das heißt
nicht einmal die standard-variante vor
körper hoch und runter und jetzt machen
wir eine etwas abgewandelte version
davon das heißt ihr habt den körper hoch
und aus der gehobenen positionen gibt es
mit den linken und mit dem rechten
ellbogen auf den boden und das ganze 30
sekunden lang sollte die varianten immer
gut umsetzbar sein wie gesagt dann
wechselt wieder auf normales abheben und
senken 30 sekunden gehts los
schöne rotation hineinbringen und wenn's
muskulär wie gesagt dann irgendwann
einmal genug ist dann gerade rauf und
runter heben
15 sekunden halbzeit ist wieder da schön
hinein drehen kopf in verlängerung der
wirbelsäule nicht über strecken an die
den heiß sondern schauen genauer dass
der wirbelsäule im bereich der
halswirbelsäule entspannt ist und 30
sekunden sei mal wieder durch rücken
aufrichten
der logische zurück links bedeutet auch
schaut nach oben blick ist in die decken
sind gestreckt nießing gestreckt becken
ist hoch das ist einmal eure
ausgangsposition
und aus dieser ausgangsposition kemmer
ist der verschiedenste übungs varianten
natürlich machen wir haben uns dazu
entschieden heute becken heben und
senken das heißt mit dem popo rich
tomate und wieder nach oben drücken und
das zweite variante auch für euch wenn
ihr das zu hause umsetzen möchten können
sie natürlich auch wechselweise in der
position dass beim hochheben und auch
hier ist ganz wichtig der kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule und er
versucht aus der schule heraus den
oberkörper eine stolze bus zu machen und
entsprechend durchzudrücken und nicht
passiv ins gelenk hineinfallen schön
herausheben zeit läuft 30 sekunden
liegestütz rücklings mit becken heben
doch 15 sie konnten wie viele stunden
kann man das zusammenfassen verbringst
du mit ausgleichsbewegungen zu deinem
radsport pro woche ja schon so drei bis
vier stunden
ja das ist schon ganz ordentlich auch
wenn wir schaffen hätten drei bis vier
stunden wöchentlich wirklich zu
trainieren
dann werden wir schon mal gut
aufgestellt 30 sekunden durch und bei
dir ist ist es quasi das ausgleichs
training also wie gesagt dass endlich
ganz andere belastungen beim
leistungssportler auch mit dabei wir
wechseln in die variante im knie stand
den lastzug wiederum haupt muskulatur in
dem verbreite rückenmuskel zu anderen
der rückenstrecke das ist nur die
ausgangsposition
das heißt im knie stand schräglage im
oberkörper nach vorn so weit dass man
nicht nach vorgibt und wir strecken die
arme nach oben und ziehen ellbogen zum
körper zurück so weit wie möglich 30
sekunden gamers wieder an 30 sekunden
arbeitszeit jetzt auch hier kopf in
verlängerung der wirbelsäule
wir brauchen auf der matte keine aero
dynamische position und den kopf
einziehen
genau dort darf sich die haare mal
bisschen entspannen und schön nach oben
und wieder nach hinten ziehen gerne
genauen versuchen mit den armen
deutschland hoch zu kommen gerne und
jetzt nach hinten und sehr gut zu 130
sekunden haben wir durch kurz die
position verlassen aber nicht weit weg
gehen weil wir bleiben gleich im knie
stand und machen entsprechend das
sortieren aus dem oberkörper
als zweite variante gleich hinten drauf
nicht gibt sagt einmal vor wieder die
schräglage ellbogen jetzt abgeschreckt
dass die hände weg und jetzt wieder
diese rotationsbewegung die man vorher
einer bauchlage gehabt haben machen wir
jetzt aus dem knie aus den knien heraus
und haben wieder volle belastung auf der
rückenstrecke muskulatur auf den
rückenstrecken drauf zeit läuft 30
sekunden geht dahin
und wie gesagt nicht nur zum ausgleichen
nicht nur zum präventiv arbeiten oder
kollektiv arbeiten für den
bahnradsportler sondern auch für euch zu
hause um entsprechend gesund sieht und
mit einem stabilen rücken in den alltag
staaten zu können seien diese übungen
ganz ganz wichtig und jederzeit dadurch
zu trainieren
30 sekunden haben wir durch und wir
seien mit dem kräftigungsübungen schon
fast am ende
zwar machen wir haben noch den hit fast
den kennt sie bereits das becken heben
aus der rückenlage und das letzte übung
dann das wasserfass wasserflasche
übergeben und die namen gemacht aber
sind auch gute übungen und wenn wie
gesagt den ganzen bereich der
rückenmuskulatur auch zu trainieren
okay wir sind am boden hände sind
daneben becken runter und hoch drücken
bis die volle spannung der hintern
anspannen
wer es etwas schwieriger haben möchte
streckt die hände nach oben in der
vorhalte wird das ganze wohl schwieriger
und wer es noch schwieriger haben möchte
hebt ein bein hoch das heißt linkes oder
rechtes bein im wechsel ausstrecken und
die 30 sekunden lass mal wieder laufen
30 sekunden arbeitszeit für beide jetzt
geht's los
wie gesagt wichtig auch hier
zehenspitzen hoch und jetzt das becken
heben und senken wenn es so schwierig
wird gibt es die hände wieder runter
dann kann der rückenmuskulatur mithelfen
und sonst was die hände vor halte und
streckt das becken rauf und runter so
weit wie er kommt sie macht sie konnten
noch ruhig weiteratmen sauerstoff in die
muskulatur hineinlassen und zeigt es aus
kurz aus lockern bereit machen für die
letzte übung trainingsutensilien flasche
ist eben mit dabei schluck trinken dann
ist nicht ganz so schwer
und dann in die bauchlage wir beginnen
vorne
das us team ausstrecken beine
ausstrecken und erst da hinten oder dem
gesäß die wasserflasche übergeben und
wieder nach vor und das macht man immer
im wechsel einmal links im kreis einmal
rechts im kreis und staaten das ganze
jetzt mit 30
und auch wenn es jetzt der nicht
unbedingt ein zusatzgewicht bei der
handhabt die übung funktioniert genauso
gut wenn man nichts in der hand hat das
heißt da kann man einfach hinten zu am
kroatischen franz am götschen ist
genauso eine option und variante wie die
übung auch ohne zusätzlichen gerät
machen kann
sehen sie konnten da sei die flasche
abstellen
aufstehen an meinem körper durch
schütteln aber aus lockern
jetzt haben wir fünf minuten wirkliche
spannung im rücken themen gehabt
arbeitszeit in der rückenmuskulatur
das ist fordert das ist anstrengend ihr
kennt keinen zweiten durchgang oder
danach dritten durchgang machen
wir wechseln jetzt in die mobilisation
hinein das heißt auf den muskulatur den
man jetzt im bereich der wirbelsäule
gestärkt und trainiert haben schauen wir
dass wir jetzt auch beweglichkeit
hineinbringen valdez glaube für euch
bahnradsportler ein wichtiger punkt ist
dass wir einmal stundenlang in einer
position ist dass man da wieder dynamik
und der beweglichkeit reinkriegt oder
den ist für uns als paar als sportler
wichtig sondern für alle sportarten die
monoton stundenlang in einer position
gemacht werden dieser mobilisierung
unerlässlich genau und nicht nur die
sportarten sondern auch für euch wenn
ihr stundenlang im büro sitzt in einer
vorgegebenen position und man kommt den
verkürzungen hin einmal kommt in eine
muskuläre displays hinein und da muss
man schauen dass man seine muskeln
kräftigt und entsprechend die gelenke
beweglich und schneidet oder ja dann
fertig sagt gehrmann mit der ersten
übung mobilisation nicht was machen
ausgangsposition in der bauchlage
mit den zehenspitzen zu den
fingerspitzen der schadstoffe super
gefährlich aus das heißt langsam
beginnen langsam in die rotation
hineingehen und wenn die zehenspitzen
nicht ganz zu den fingerspitzen
community gab ist das trotzdem gute
mobilisation und ist nicht ganz so
tragisch oder also nicht ausdenken oder
aus kugeln gegen der gelenke in dem
bereich der beweglichkeit in dem es ihr
arbeiten kennt in dem bereich bleibt sie
halbzeit hammer 15 sekunden mobilisieren
nicht mit schwung in die opposition
hinein reißen sondern schauen dass man
das schön über die beweglichkeit
arbeiten und in einer dynamischen
lockeren vor das ganze machen und
erledigen können
30 sekunden durch erste übung haben wir
schon mobilisiert als zweites geht man
mit angewinkelten beinen im sitzen das
ist wieder eine bekannte altbekannte
übung das heißt leicht geöffnete beine
und das knie links und rechts zum boden
hinunter bewegen das haben als ganz
stark im bereich lendenwirbelsäule
unterer rücken beziehungsweise auch
hüftgelenk drinnen und dass er von
seiner kollegin kehrt hüfte ist also
knackpunkt bei euch oder kannst bringst
du mir leistung aufs pedal ja was bei
uns unerlässlich ist einerseits stabil
für den sport und andererseits wieder
mobil für den alltag oder weil wenn du
deine position vom rat nicht wieder
auflösen kannst dann ist genauso dann
ist genau so blöde ja er ist genauso
schlecht
genauso ist es deswegen auch das
mobilisieren für die gelenke dann ganz
wichtiger punkt okay
ich glaube hüfte und unter dem rücken
haben wir ganz gut erledigt was zu haben
wir für variante für den bereich
wirbelsäule gerade was können wir da hin
ohne rotation also welches tier auch
immer in erinnerung kommt wenn ihr die
nici dafür übernehmen letzteres
eselsbrücke her und einen höheren
drücken bitte nach oben durchdrücken und
jetzt in eine lose in einem pferderücken
wie auch immer in der zweiten position
und es wechseln mal bäume hin und her
[Musik]
gates war meine auf und ab wechseln
und wieder ausloggen langsam aus der
position wieder heraus kommen damit
durch lockern wieder aufstehen aus
lockern und wir gehen in die nächste
variante im stehen das heißt sich
aufrecht hin hände kann seitlich
herunter hängen lassen und beginnt bei
der halswirbelsäule einfach wirbel für
wirbel abrollen bisher mit den
fingerspitzen so weiter unten satz wie
möglich und dann richtet sich wieder auf
und kommt wieder beginnen talente
wirbelsäule wir wieder aufrollen
nach oben nicht wenn du oben bist dafür
die bieten dresden um 90° dass man das
von der seite asien wie das ausschauen
und beim heiß beginn über die
brustwirbelsäule die inserenten wir
müssen alle schauen wir dass wir das
schön einen runden rücken hinkriegen und
dem aufrichten beginn wieder herunten
und waren dann immer weiter nach oben
bis man da im ganzen rücken eine auf
richtung hinkriegen einmal noch runter
und einmal noch aus
genau so schaut es aus wie gesagt kein
stress bei diesen übungen da können wir
ganz ruhig und entspannt schauen dass
man in die mobilisation von unseren
gelenken reinkommen nachdem er gesagt
haben nicht nur für den
leistungssportler sondern auch für für
büro sitzen für auto fahren ja viele
positionen die wenig bewegung haben wir
dafür stunden am tag da drinnen ist ist
die hüfte sicherlich eines der gelenke
was man schauen muss dass man beweglich
hält und da gibt es ja ganz gute
variante die haben das letzte mal schon
vorgestellt das heißt im knie stand die
beine so weit wie möglich auseinander
90 grad nach hinten die unterschenkel
weg gestreckt in eine position leicht
also gerade bis leichtes hohlkreuz im
rücken und jetzt aspekten nach hinten
schieben so dass wir entsprechend eine
zugbelastung an in der in der hüfte
tränen spürt und wenn die hüfte die
beweglichkeit doch gar nicht begrenzt
sondern entsprechend es die muskulatur
in der oberschenkel einen seite das ist
was am meisten liegt dann ist das akku
zu
dann darf das genauso sein ihr wert
segen über kurz oder lang kommt sie in
die position so dass der muskel die
spannung löst und dann kriegst wirklich
die belastung ins hüftgelenk hinein wo
man mit der übung in wahrheit hin wollen
das kann er machen
zehnmal das kann eben auch in zwanzig
mal das kann ich machen 50 mal es ist
ganz egal bewegt die hüfte heraus dass
darin die beweglichkeit hinein kommt das
ist wie gesagt ganz ganz wichtiger punkt
sowohl für einen leistungssportler wie
auch für otto normalverbraucher für dich
und mich
fünfmal noch nach vor und zurück
und wenn durch langsam wiederum aus der
position heraus kommen langsam aufstehen
und einmal die beine ausschütteln und
regeneration da reinbringen
wenn das aber nur zwickt am anfang wie
gesagt es ist okay jetzt hier mit der
übung spürt man dass dies natürlich ein
thema was mich anspricht genauso ist es
okay was machen wir nächstes niki und da
wären wir wieder unterschiedliche
varianten reinbringen so dass man dort
den kompletten bereich der wirbelsäule
abdecken können das heißt wir beginnen
einfach einmal oberkörper links und
rechts verdrehen die hände nehmen
schwung was sie mit das becken bewegt
sich mitunter kopf bewegt sie damit also
alle bereiche der wirbelsäule jetzt in
der rotation gesamt betrachtet und auf
diese bewegung fixieren einmal den kopf
das ist der blick ist geradeaus und er
vertritt setzt er den oberkörper und das
becken dazu das heißt jetzt haben wir
wesentlich mehr rotation im bereich der
halswirbelsäule tränen und aus dieser
bewegung heraus stabilisieren wir jetzt
noch das becken das heißt gürtel abwärts
bleibt ruhig und es bewegt sich nur
ihnen drinnen heraus der oberkörper nach
links und rechts so trainer zusätzliche
mobile belastung im bereich der
lendenwirbelsäule noch mit hinein und
somit hammer den ganzen bereich der
wirbelsäule auch mit der übung abgedeckt
wieder kurz aus locker auf die position
hüft eröffnen in der variante 1 schauen
wir uns die zweite variante an weil das
hüftgelenk ist ja kugelgelenk und das
kann ihnen ganz viel und
bewegungsrichtungen belasten und das ist
eine variante an die dafür die bitten
noch einmal in die ausgangsposition knie
breit auseinander
90 grad unterschenkel ab strecken genau
jetzt auf den ellbogen und jetzt ist
aber normal mit dem geraden rücken der
leichten diagnose hineinzieht schiebe
ich nach hinten und schaue dass ich
immer darum kämpfen die position dass
ich im 1
ratlose bleibe das heißt nieder in eine
in einer runden bereich der wirbelsäule
hinein kommen sondern immer schauen ich
so gut wie es geht da in der dose zu
bleiben und die entsprechend nach hinten
zu drücken
und wer kommt es wieder genau jenen
bereich der beweglichkeit in der hüfte
rein
wie gesagt ich wiederhole mich da gerne
was man schon den ganzen die ganze halbe
stunde sprechen der ganz wichtig für
euch ist manchmal noch fünfmal
und wenn fertig einfach wieder aufstehen
und ausloggen eine variante eine übung
zu mobilisieren haben wir nur das heißt
die erste variante war bauchlage hände
weg strecken und quasi über den rücken
das ganze ab
und jetzt haben wir damit auch mit der
zweiten variante er legt sich auf den
rücken
streckt die arme links und rechts weg
und berührt mit den zehenspitzen die
übernahme die fingerspitzen wie gesagt
jetzt in der rückenlage und cellos werk
auch hier ohne stress ohne druck einfach
schauen dass man die mobilität im rücken
verbessern können
das einen entspannenden übungen da
braucht man jetzt kann großartigen
rückkehr reißen keine übertrieben
dynamischen bewegungen sondern schön
langsam hin und her der arbeiten wie
gesagt an der mobilität und das ist der
punkt wenn viele oft in ihrem training
vernachlässigen
zweimal pro seite
und wenn durch steht einfach wieder auf
und lockert sich aus ich fand's noch
einmal kurz zusammen was haben wir jetzt
gemeinsam geschafft wir haben gemeinsam
zuerst intensives rückentraining gemacht
wo er gerne in euren zweiten dritten
durchgang alleine jetzt daran machen
kannst und dann haben wir geschaut dass
man die beweglichkeit einerseits über
die wirbelsäule und andererseits ein
hüftgelenk noch verbessern einfach damit
ihr gut auch in den tag starten kennt
und entsprechend leistungsfähig andreas
was gibst du den leuten zu hause mit
jetzt da wieso ist sie ins frühjahr wie
kann man den übergang in das sportlich
schaffen
ich denke mit bewegung in der natur es
genießen man die natur aufgenommen als
grün wird jeder menschen also draußen
bewegt ist für unser gesundheitssystem
besser und man wird dazu beitragen dass
man da jetzt leute motivieren können
besitzen bewegen haben unser ziel aber
ich bin genauso sieht es auch das heißt
geht es raus bewegt sich motiviert sich
auch an der frischen luft etwas zu tun
nehmt das mit wie gesagt der frühling
ist da es bewegt sich ganz viel in der
natur bewegt sich mit und dann kommt
sehr fit über das jahr und entsprechend
gesund in auch die nächste winters ist
sondern hinein
okay das war's von meiner seite sagt
danke
der eine sagt danke gesagt danke wir
sehen uns zur nächsten trainingseinheit
morgen